Ngay Mề Ba của tháng người, túng là ngày thứ 18, trừng kiến của con khoảng nân xách tại Mỹ,
hai đảng lớn dân chủ và con ngoà vẫn chưa tìm được tiểu nói chung, trong khi hàng chợi nguyên bán tiếp tục biển hưởng vì chính phủ ngon hoạt động.
Lánh đạo phay thiểu số tại thường viện ông Trắc Sù Mơ thuận dân chủ đến bố, sẽ không ủng hộ dựa là sạm ở của đảng cộng ngoà,
nếu không bao gồm gặp u diền hàng về trong xác xức quay, đắp lại, chú tình hả viện maj Johnson thuật lạng cộng ngoà,
chỉ chết các khoảng chi cho chung trình của bà mà kè là lạ phía, cảnh bảo đất nước, lạng tiền gần một trong lợt đồng cơ chính phủ, giải nhất lix sử.
Zù thông viện Mỹ sửt kiến bò phíao lạng ngày 14, sông phay cũng hoạt vẫn thiểu ít nhất, năm phíao tử, phía Zanchu,
để gọi qua thu tục biểu quên.
Một số nghĩa sẽ í đã để sớt thay đổi cuy tóc bò phíau, nhưng lạng đạo cùng hoạt phản đối,
lòng ngại tạo tiền lệ miệng, cho nên đếp chính phía Mỹ tựa lai.
Chóng bú cảnh đỏ khoảng một phía tư, chữ công trước lên bà của Mỹ vẫn đang nghĩ việc,
phóng phải làm không lương, nhiều công quan phải các giảm những sự, trong đó có bộ giật rục và cơ quan hàng không bú chủ nâsa.
Tổng thủ Mỹ đồ năng trông hàng đyện, mặc dù đã tạm thời đảm bảo được cuy trả lương cho con nhân,
sông chưa có kế hoạt cho các khoảng chi khác.
Zù ấy có xanh nhận định nếu tình trạng này kéo dài, nếu Mỹ có thể đối mắt không chỉ với tổ thích kinh tế,
mà còn với một cuộc không hoạt niềm tiền chính khị sâu sắc.